c'est jean yanne
comment ça va il ya des moments on
croirait qu'on est mort la dernière fois
vous êtes venu il ya quoi il ya un nom
pour un livre déjà un
on a tout raconté des gens à part
commencé varicent face ça tout de suite
pour me foute la paix non non les 9 et
le faire oui toute façon la dernière
fois que vous êtes venu on va parler de
votre vie la drogue la prostitution
oui et puis on avait parlé de votre
aventure avec
on va recommencer on va passer à la
promo directement vous êtes prêts pour
faire des petites mains là j'étais bien
faux pas
il faut pas dire ah non c'est pas bien
mais il faut rentrer dans le truck
series pourquoi pour faire la promotion
d'un livre aux éditions du cherche midi
que j'ai écris moi même et qui s'appelle
je suis un être exclue alors c'est un
recueil de pensées d'articles de texte
extraordinaire comme tout ce que vous
faites toute façon depuis que depuis que
je vous connais le ton est donné dès la
page de garde vous dites je n'ai plus
aucun propos dignes de confiance
j'ai tout dit j'ai menti à tout le monde
je ne sais plus ce que j'ai signé qui
voilà comme ça au moins c'est clair
non c'est pas la peine de dire rares
j'ai plongé dans mes souvenirs est ce
que je dis est sincère j'ai jeune jaime
sage faire profiter le monde demain de
mes découvertes et de la connaissance
jeudi je m'en fous ça vous va bien d'un
coût de 90 balle c'est aux éditions du
cherche midi
bah voilà et c'est bientôt noël
en attendant raison je venais des cages
vous allez lire les maximes que j'ai
noté vous êtes prêts oui page 14
l'amour est aveugle la preuve en le
faisant il ya des gens qui braille
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur des
convoyeurs de son 21 membres ne mâchait
pas ses mots heureusement pour lui les
bonnes femmes sont toutes les mêmes
elles nous insultent parce qu'on arrive
en retard et elle nous demande pourquoi
on n'a pas appelé pour ne pas se faire
insulter deux fois toi continue gratuite
c'est quand on commence à payer des
pensions alimentaires comme se rend
compte à quel point moi ça passe vite
mais continue un peu ça va ils ont il
faut leur en laisser un peu j'espère
qu'ils achètent plus après non c'est pas
ça mais c'est parce que toujours un peu
bébête quand quand on est quand on
raconte soi même les trucs 87 87
je serais à la place des agriculteurs
qui dépose du fumier devant les mcdo je
me méfierais parce que les gérants vont
finir par croire qu'il s'agit d'une
livre
à